[Music]
oh my gosh
stop it both of you oh why is he alive
why is he here
it's over jerry i'm calling in the boys
and guys
why do you have prita's ring have you
had it this entire time
give it to me now drop the ring
what do you want part jerry
you want to stay here you little con
artist fine
we can discuss this on red terms
where did he go where did he go
[Music]
why do i see temporary employees
socializing on hotel property in the
middle of their shift
we were just terrance was celebrating
you know the uh hotel's mouth problem's
taken care of oh yeah congratulations
teamwork is dreamwork right yeah it's
taken care of right tom
it is so taken care of right
tom what is he doing he's not doing
nothing why are you acting nervous huh
you're acting nervous i'm not acting
nervous
no what's in your pocket ah
nah oh turn wait no he said what do you
do [ __ ] it the monster's in the book
oh i'm so sorry
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
this is definitely your bed
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies
[Music]
tom and jerry are about to start over
cause that's what friends are supposed
to do
[Music]
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings and
we're about to host the wedding of the
century
do you think you're qualified to take on
this position i shine under pressure
like a diamond
or rihanna one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the whatnot
i'll catch it sir
everybody's gonna shine
like this don't even gotta try oh wow
this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator oh we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory evolution
if a picture of this mouse is tweeted up
to insta book face or tiki talk
we will be warned no sir that's not
gonna happen
that rodent is toast
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat and a mouth
he's dying with us
i think i might have just pulled this
off really
bouncy bouncy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye